this is Ground Zero in the city of jabla
in Syrian Latakia District
controlled here but its means of
intervention after Monday's earthquake
seem as limited as those of the rebels
thousands of deaths have been reported
in government-held territories
the Syrian Ministry of Health calls on
all United Nations members agencies
foundations the red crescent and other
non-governmental and governmental
organizations to lend a helping hand in
responding to the humanitarian disaster
in Syria Syrian government is ready to
help to support any countries who wanted
to provide the shelters the food supply
the medications to the syrians anywhere
in Syria the needed measures according
to Damascus include the lifting of
Western sanctions and the opening of
more border crossings which is all
subject to a U.N security Council
resolution the United States has already
issued a six-month exemption on
sanctions to allow Aid into affected
areas we are determined to do what we
can to address the humanitarian needs of
the Syrian people we've done that over
the course of the 12-year Civil War to
the tune of billions of dollars we do
that through a different process in
Turkey we have a partner in the
government in Syria we have a partner in
the form of ngos on the ground who are
providing humanitarian support
Syrian State media are reporting the
government has approved a delivery to
rebel-held areas through Aid agencies
including the icrc Syrian red crescent
and the U.N
the Syrian presidency shared these
pictures of President basharon Assad and
his wife visiting earthquake victims at
Aleppo University Hospital on Friday
analysts believe his real aim is to end
his own political isolation I do think
he is seeking political Advantage I
think he will try to leverage This
Disaster to the extent possible to
promote uh the resumption of relations
with other Arab Nations other Regional
Nations and and internationally to the
extent possible for the U.N Secretary
General the priority now is to bring Aid
to the victims by any means this is a
moment in which everybody must make very
clear that no sanctions of any kind
interfere with relief to the population
of Syria in the present moment the first
U.N shipments of Aid were sent on
Thursday through the northern bab alhawa
border crossing with turkey and the U.N
says it has sent an appeal to
International donors
meanwhile several countries are already
sending Aid by air through Damascus
International Airport Muhammad
al-jazeera